I was going to say you had a couple of
you have in your store back in the day
resulted in some cool [__] one obviously
I think the last hurray was kind of
a gun in my face well I was gonna say
when when X passed away and you guys
pretty much shut
that was crazy but then the thing that
actually made us like basically leave
the block was when I got the gun in my
face that seemed like that kind of like
killed the vibe and you know all of a
sudden I didn't want to be there the
same way I needed security around me
whenever I was there everybody's got
guns everybody's just like on a very
different level because we were hanging
out all the [__] time with no guns
around for years there and then all of a
sudden one kid pulls up back and crazy
and that just kind of really changed the
flavor of the block
um I was gonna say though like you had a
dope interaction with J Cole where he
just fell through randomly and Shout Out
Sasha who he just named he's the one who
basically lined that up shout out to
Sasha good guy uh and then um I think
about MGK Kevin came and bought a bike
at your store did he yeah that's
something to him and I talked about
because he was like you know I bought a
bike from that store really and he said
that's why he doesn't understand why
because I guess you were [__] on him
you guys have this like you guys had
like a little I remember real dude I
never knew do why he had an issue with
me aside for like the only things I
could think of probably said something
that he saw he's a sensitive guy yeah I
mean I'm sure you said something about
him yeah I mean I don't like his rap
like his all his rap records back in the
day I I remember like he put a record
out and I listened to it and I said it
was garbage and I never really bought a
bike from me though so it's funny
because yeah because him and I because
you know I'm real cool with cows and and
we were talking and I was like you know
Adam like I can connect you Adam he's a
good because you know I don't know if
you remember I put you on the phone with
Russ
oh yeah you did and I we had like a
conversation that I always think about
that because I had a conversation
thinking that we were on air
we weren't I know right I was having the
conversation like I was trying to film
it yeah but then I realized after like
oh that wasn't on air like no only
people who know about that conversation
are me Russ and Kev whereas I was
speaking as if I had the whole world
listening to me but damn that's crazy
you had that conversation with MGK
because I never got that's what he told
me he was like it's crazy because I
actually went out of my way to make sure
when I bought a bike I bought it from
his store just to kind of keep the money
within like the culture type [__] I
don't think anybody ever told me like at
the store that that happened it's
possible that no he said he bought a
bike he's like I bought a bike from from
his spot I literally went out of my way
to go buy the bike somebody should have
told me yeah because I look at all that
like oh why do I have problems with MGK
like why why was he so mad at me it's
really just for me like saying I didn't
like his music at a certain point or
like making fun of him and I mean I
really am not like a big fan of his
music but also like I'm sure me and him
would get along all right and like I
remember uh somebody told me that he
lives near me And so I've had the
thought multiple times when I'm doing
cardio just walking around the
neighborhood just thinking like imagine
I just saw MGK and we just had to fight
in the front yard like that would be
crazy
because like if he came up to me on some
crazy [__] I guess I'm just gonna fight
him even though that's not normally an
option for right I'm not normally gonna
like I think both both of you guys are
too rich for that to happen I would
think so as well but I mean you've seen
him punch some guy at the fair the other
day I got nothing against him yeah but I
mean that was I think that was more I
mean his lady was nearby yeah I I you
know yeah you got to kind of hold your
chick down and yeah but somebody said
some crazy [__] to her and then he had
his security right there for me if
somebody said something crazy to us to
my girl I'm gonna be like security get
him like I'm paying you for a reason but
he's had security for so long
he's a hot head you know like like I've
seen like Kelsey you know he's a good
dude but yeah you guys I'm sure one day
we'll have a conversation or you'll be
jogging and he'll honk at you from a
pink G wagon I'm down or something like
that I would have a conversation with
him yeah